Trump's been going after DeSantis
relentlessly and attacking Florida we
played the he went after Kaylee mcinany
yesterday which I think actually has
shifted things a little bit you know
it's one thing when Trump goes after all
of like the the Deep State people or he
goes after like middle management
government people CAA people
etc etc but Kaylee was so outwardly a
defender of him and did it so well at
the height of covet with the Hostile
media that I even saw some of Trump's
most loyal backers yesterday finally
being like enough is enough like this
guy who talks about loyalty all the time
who has he not turned against I I ask
you I would ask you that
who has he not turned against how is it
possible that everyone he's ever worked
with is a sellout and a rhino and a
globalist and an idiot whether it's
Christopher Ray or it's John Bolton or
it's Chris Christie or it's Kaylee like
everybody has somehow turned against him
and it's always their fault it doesn't
quite make sense anyway DeSantis was
campaigning yesterday in Iowa and uh
somebody in the media asked him about
Trump's attacks and Florida I thought
this response was pretty solid
so you talked about uh changing her tone
a little bit with former president Trump
I don't believe you mentioned him here
by name tonight but does this mean
you're going to be a bit more aggressive
with campaigning against him so look I'm
going to respond to uh attacks I mean if
if you say Cuomo did a better job with
covid then Florida did first of all
that's not what he used to say this is
like new like six months ago he would
have never said that right he used to
say how great Florida was hell his whole
family moved to Florida under my
governorship are you kidding me
um
so so some of
some of the thing is look if someone is
saying that I am gonna I'm gonna counter
punch I'm gonna fight back on it I'm
gonna Focus my fire on Biden and I think
he should do the same he gives Biden a
free pass I'm focusing on Biden that's
my focus
you know it's not that hard to speak
clearly when you're telling the truth
right
it's just as simple as that it's not
that hard to be funny when you're doing
something true to link it to what we
were talking about a moment ago but it
is true like all of Trump's family lives
here now uh several of his kids and all
of his grandchildren moved to Florida
during covid because of the policies of
Ron DeSantis Trump is not attacking
Biden at all I would recommend you look
at Trump's truth social feed you could
look at Jason Miller who I think is the
campaign manager look at his Twitter
it's all against DeSantis right and
DeSantis said the right thing I'm not
going to spend all day attacking him but
I will respond to attacks and again the
reason I'm laying this out for you guys
the way I am is I think there is a more
mature way to do all of this and we're
starting to see it it is being born and
I don't think we want it to be stillborn
I think we want it to be born and given
a chance to grow and I think that is
what I will do
as we continue this crazy year and a
half
[Music]